having supportive parents help were they
supportive of you are they are they
still like
go beau you're doing great how are they
yeah they're they're very supportive too
supportive
my father uh googles me a lot and i know
this because
my sister went on his computer to print
something out and
saw his google history took a picture of
it and sent it to me
and i brought it here he does not know i
have this he does
he definitely doesn't know about to show
it on national television you're gonna
show it here yeah it's horrifying
this is this is the most joyous moment
this is and this is real and your father
doesn't know this is happening yeah this
is my father's
uh horrifying google history okay the
first sport pretty easy is a boston guy
he's looking for bruins tickets cheap
brewing stick it's all normal and then
it takes a sharp
left turn in the next search if we can
go okay next search
what the hell which i i'll give i'll
give him credit for like going for not
the first measurement you think
of when you're worried about it but like
the only thing worse than girth is
misspelling girth
the only thing creepier see this is real
and he doesn't know that you're showing
this on television yeah he's horrified
and i'm
i'm thrilled right now this is a great
moment so uh then he flawlessly segues
to the next one which is
me why i'm hoping this is like the day
after that he searched this
and he didn't just like seamlessly
transition from the width of his penis
to his baby boy
they are kind of related
by god okay so he went from that okay
and then if you uh
keep going from there so now he's back
to the ticket tick with liquidator which
makes me think
he bought the tickets realized he has a
skinny penis is now like i can't go to
the
i can't possibly go to a bruins game
with my little noodle
will you hear from him about this
obviously this could be the end of it
but it's worth it
okay uh and then you can go to the next
two uh this i don't even want to i don't
even want to
whoa i don't even want to get into what
that is but and then if we can go to the
the big finale at the end s'mores bars
and what's really nice about that image
is that it's the perfect shape
for a headstone
nothing that that sums up my father's
life better than anything
should probably be all of our headstones
is our google searches our most
embarrassing
truth of our soul is is bruins to girth
to s'mores bars